bonjour à tous effectivement en
bourgogne franche comté les métiers de
bouche représente quasiment un apprenti
sur cinq bonjour fabrice courbet bonjour
alors on se trouve dans vos cuisines
vous êtes traiteur a besoin sont je le
vois à votre colle vous êtes meilleur
ouvrier de france forcément
l'apprentissage chez vous c'est
important vince est important c'est un
outil de recrutement est principalement
faut préparer l'avenir
donc c'est avec des gens qu'on va encore
essayer de former de conserver ces
jeunes voulaient récupérer on va dire
généralement en sortie de troisième
c'est ça et qu'elle est va être leur
formation alors ça va être
principalement sortie de troisième mais
ça peut être plus tard il ya des gens
qui sort de baccalauréat et qui viennent
en apprentissage et la formation va être
spécifiquement sur chaque métier dont
qui va être la charcuterie la boucherie
la cuisine et la pâtisserie alors la
pâtisserie on ira voir tout à l'heure
mais ce que je vous propose c'est que
nous comme c'est une spéciale
apprentissage
on a aussi notre apprenti robin crumière
étudiant en école de journalisme
et bien c'est toi robin qui colle
maintenant pour l'interview de damien
très bien merci beaucoup clément on se
retrouve donc avec damien alors damien
racontez moi un petit peu depuis combien
de temps est-ce que vous travaillez ici
pour faire neuf mois que je suis sur
neuf mois l'accord est pourquoi est-ce
que vous travaillez pour fabrice prouver
ce que je pense que ça mur maison en
franche-comté pourra prendre le dessus
d'accord c'était quelque part une
satisfaction aussi pour vous de
travailler dans un grand nom chez un
grand nombre pardon alors racontez moi
un petit peu qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que
vous faites
le champion d'affaires de taille et de
compte pour une salade pour celui d'il
pour le restaurant d'accord pour ce midi
vous savez une quarantaine de couverts
si je ne me trompe pas d'accord qu'est
ce que vous préférez faire à votre poste
je vais me faire tous tout ce qu'on fait
à ce poste ici après j'aime bien tailler
les légumes faire des terrines de
poisson
d'accord vous êtes plus accès quand même
sur la charcuterie très bien malgré moi
un petit peu votre cursus comment est-ce
que vous en êtes arrivés là finalement
voilà en sortie de troisième cherchent à
ce que je voulais faire comme métier
oui donc j'ai choisi de faire un crp une
boucherie et j'ai su en europe et
charcuterie pour qu'en complément très
bien et comment vous voyez dans dix ans
par exemple j'aimerais bien être sur
d'entreprise d'accord devenir vous même
traiteur très bien merci beaucoup damien
monsieur courbes et damien c'est un bon
élément pour très bon un très bon
élément qui a qui s'est très bien
intégré dans l'entreprise un peu timide
au départ mais ils ont commencé à se
délier on va dire très bien moi ça me
semble pas mal là j'interviens à nouveau
robin il faut qu'on travaille les
d'accord 1 quand on répond quand la
personne interviewée répond à vos
questions on évite les d'accord ce que
je vous propose c'est qu'on va se
retrouver dans quelques secondes tout de
suite du côté à des cuisines pour les
voir cette fois ci la préparation de
sucre et on va retrouver là-bas deux
apprentis et c'est robin encore qui va
s'y coller
zine et nous sommes passés du salé au
sucré je me trouve actuellement avec
taha bonjour tara vous avez 21 ans et
vous avez un cursus un peu particulier
racontez moi j'ai commencé par un bac es
en général et après je suis parti j'ai
fait un an de fac de droit avant de
commencer mon apprentissage d'accord
qu'est ce qui vous a donné envie de vous
réorienter dans les métiers de bouche
j'ai toujours eu envie de faire ça et
j'ai fini par me décider un peu sur le
tard mais tout petit vous cuisinier déjà
avec vos parents n'ont tout seul mais
oui souvent chez moi tout seul donc
finalement vous êtes vraiment dans votre
élément oui très bien
racontez moi un petit peu une journée
type chez fabrice pour becker ce que
vous faites vous à votre poste le matin
en arrivant on commence à préparer le
magasin je m'occupe plus de la partie
tarte
après ça je fais les commandes
extérieures les cocktails tout ce qui
est mignardises macarons tout ce qui va
partir et après c'est la mise en place
diverses qu'on a pour le magasin les
biscuits les crises à l'avenir vous
alors vous êtes spécialisé actuellement
en pâtisserie chocolat vous comptez
également toucher aux autres corps de
métiers qui sont propres au métier de
traiteur
non je veux plus rester dans le sucre
est je pense plus stressés dans le sucre
est d'accord merci beaucoup je me dirige
maintenant vers nicolas alors nicolas
vous avez 17 ans ça fait combien de
temps que vous travaillez pour pour
fabrice gobert trois ans que je suis ici
en tant qu'apprenti d'accord en tant
qu'apprenti vous avez donc validé un c
ap pâtisserie ce soit sur deux ans et
vous êtes actuellement nos j'ai passé
mon simple et chocolat
j'attends les résultats très bien
racontez nous un petit peu ce que ce que
vous faites nicolas là je fais les tarte
citron framboise qu'on va mettre au
magasin après donc c'est un crime et au
citron confit framboises avec un dôme se
trouve juste ici mais après ont décoré
avec des framboises fraîches vous
mettez combien de temps pour préparer
ces petites pâtisseries entre 5 7 min 3
5 et 7 minutes mais ça dépend du nom
qu'on va voir aussi très bien merci
beaucoup je vous propose maintenant de
laisser la main à clément janequin
effectivement a effectivement robin
alors fabrice eux qu'est ce que vous
pensez de notre apprenti à nous emballer
il est passionné de ski fait déjà et
c'est déjà une grande c'est déjà une
grande chose mais ensuite ben cc il faut
se lancer il ya un moment ou un autre il
faut se lancer
c'est une très bonne épreuve en quelques
secondes la pâtisserie là mais les
métiers de bouche généralement ont une
mauvaise image par le passé alors que
c'est grâce à recruter c'est bon pour
les jeunes il faut se lancer là dedans à
largs une énorme
il ya un énorme manque de personnel dans
le milieu de la des métiers de bouche
donc il faut absolument revaloriser ces
métiers de manière à les rendre plus
attrayants peut-être et il ya une vraie
ya une vraie passion une vraie
créativité un portier effectivement et
on l'a vu avec tara avec nicolas et
damien on peut a commencé directement
sortie de troisième ou bien faire des
études à voir son baccalauréat et si lui
reprendre après l'important c'est de
faire de l'apprentissage parce que on
l'a bien vu avec robin et ben c'est en
forgeant qu'on devient forgeron voilà
c'est la fin de ce direct spécial
apprentissage ici à la maison courbet